[Musique]
nous passons à l'interview politique de
ce 20 novembre avec françois morton
bonsoir vous êtes le maire de guyancourt
candidat à un nouveau mandat bien que mr
c'est votre première campagne en tant
que tête de liste cette fois-ci 2014 je
restitue françois de ligne est élu il
démissionne en 2016 marie-christine le
tarnec devient mère elle quitte à son
tour le poste pour des raisons de santé
nous sommes en maître 2019 vous devenez
mer cette mandature a été agitée dans
les rangs de la majorité
est ce qu'il faut le traduire comme ça
alors oui on nous renvoie effectivement
très souvent les trois maires durant le
mandat françois de ligné a été maire
pendant 14 ans il a expliqué
effectivement les résines son départ et
c'était important cette action de passer
la main cette transmission se relaient
marie-christine le tarnec je ne vais pas
en dire plus vous avez de le dire on ne
peut pas envisager des raisons de santé
et j'étais son premier adjoint d'une
manière très cohérente et très logique
je suis devenu maire le monde mai
dernier et pour mener le travail au
quotidien mené le projet au quotidien
durant ces cinq ans les choses ont pu se
faire est ce que aujourd'hui déjà d'une
part vous assumez pleinement ce bilan de
cette équipe sortante même si elle a été
elle a évolué et puis quel quel regard
vous portez sur le travail réalisé ces
cinq dernières années alors le regard
que je porte sur sur le mandat sur
l'intégralité du mandat alors est-ce une
particularité je ne sais pas mais
toujours est il que l'ensemble des
engagements qui avaient été faits en
2014 ont été tenus ou sont en voie de
l'être
donc j'ai envie de dire que par le fait
j'assume pleinement évidemment ses
engagements et ce mandat et
l'intégralité de ce mandat
maintenant nous avons agi effectivement
en sorte et nous avons tenu l'ensemble
de ses mandats je pense à quelques
exemples la réhabilitation du maïdo sol
par exemple qui était un engagement la
réalisation d'un relais d'assistants
maternels qui était également un
engagement et nous avons été au delà car
il faut aussi tenir compte de
l'adaptation du rendement d'afrique nous
avons donc eu un certain nombre de
réalisations qui n'était pas mais qui
était en plus voilà donc peut-être vous
parlez d'assumer donc ce mandat ces
réalisations pleinement en 2014 françois
de ligné
était au parti socialiste tête de liste
parti socialiste aujourd'hui vous vous
présentez comme divers gauche inouïe est
ce que votre liste aura une investiture
des soutiens ou est-ce que vous restez
sur cette étiquette plus large alors
d'étiquettes et les divers gauche a des
très simple à expliquer je n'adhère à
aucun parti politique
et comme il a été historiquement le cas
pour la liste guyancourt pour tous
personne ne demandait une adhésion à un
parti politique pour faire partie de
cette liste
on a besoin de citoyens engagés qui
veulent effectivement s'engager pour
l'heure leur ville et ce sera encore le
cas
ce coup ci pas de soutiens pas
d'investiture non en tout cas
officiellement vous ne demandez pas si
on vous l'accordé j'imagine annoncé
longtemps les jeunes mamans d'aucune et
je n'ai eu aucune proposition vous étiez
25e sur la liste en 2014 ensuite vous
êtes devenu premier adjoint ensuite mr
j'imagine que le parcours vous n'y avais
pas pensé auparavant
c'est assez inattendu c'est assez
surprenant est ce que vous vous êtes
posé la question ensuite lorsqu'il a
fallu très vite se décider et être tête
de liste et candidat puisque vous êtes
devenu maire en mai dernier une étape
intermédiaire que vous n'avez pas cité
c'est que j'ai été adjoint avant d'être
premier adjoint aussi donc effectivement
j'ai eu ce parcours-là qui n'était comme
vous l'avez dit pas prévu au démarrage
il ya une cohérence dans ce parcours
j'étais adjoint très rapidement puisque
dès le mois de novembre 2014 j'étais
adjoint donc j'étais assez peu longtemps
conseiller municipal délégué mes
adjoints dès novembre 2014 et premier
adjoint 2016 donc le parcours il peut
sembler effectivement assez rapide mais
il a sa cohérence
il ya eu un renouvellement un changement
en tout cas au sein du conseil municipal
on l'a vu pendant le mandat est ce que
votre liste sera va repartir avec les
mêmes éléments est ce qu'il ya des
changements on a vu des candidatures se
déclarer je pense à olivier paréja par
exemple qui était sur votre liste
en 2014 qui aujourd'hui est tête de
liste pour un autre mouvement
il va y avoir une recomposition une
évolution alors oui heureusement j'ai
envie de dire que c'est assez
traditionnel le taux de renouvellement
il est assez traditionnel d'environ 50%
ce sera probablement effectivement le
même la même configuration pour ce
mandat et c'est normal on a besoin d'une
ossature à la fois d'élus expérimentés
et de terrain parce que tous les élus
sont des élus de terrain je me dis
toujours donc forcément expérimenté
c'est important et c'est pas simple
toujours de gérer une ville faut jamais
l'oublier
et puis c'est important d'avoir aussi de
nouveaux élus
avec un regard neuf avec une vision
nouvelle de la ville de guyancourt et
plusieurs listes à gauche ce n'est pas
un regret ne pas réussir à fédérer plus
largement on peut le regretter
nous on peut le regretter je ne peux que
le regretter ce n'est pas mon choix
voilà c'est plutôt le choix d'autres
listes je ne sais pas s'il ya d'autres
listes de gauche en l'occurrence voilà
grâce elle en tout cas déclarés
d'olivier paréja qui qui porte un
mouvement participatif nous en avons
parlé lors des précédentes éditions du 7
8 politique parlant de votre programme
à présent solidarité éducation
développement durable ce sont les trois
axes principaux
oui alors c'était les axes principaux
j'ai envie de dire du monde a déjà 2014
2020 et j'ai presque envie de dire que
nous nous basons sur des convictions et
des valeurs
effectivement qui sont les valeurs de
notre liste c'est à dire une liste de
gauche je le dis toujours alors c'est
ses valeurs et ses convictions et ses
piliers il existe toujours bien
évidemment mais on peut aussi envisager
et c'est le cas actuellement puisque
vous savez probablement nous sommes sur
des ateliers de construction de ce
programme ce programme n'est évidemment
pas figé hier soir j'étais encore avec
environ 80 habitants de la ville de
guyancourt et nous continuerons à
construire ce programme et d'autres
thématiques évidemment émergeront ce
sera le 30 novembre prochain la
prochaine réunion la restitution de
l'ensemble de ces ateliers puisqu'il y
en a eu 2 les deux derniers mariés aura
lieu le 30 novembre prochain à 10h du
matin effectivement dans le quartier de
villas roy ont parlé de ces trois axes
de programmes est ce que la sécurité
aussi rentrer en ligne de compte
aujourd'hui on voit dans la plupart des
communes la sécurité est une demande
importante de la part des concitoyens
ou alors il faut la traiter avec sérieux
on l'appelle sécurité on appelle
tranquillité publique on peut l'appeler
des divers noms mais bien sûr ça doit
être traitée avec le plus grand sérieux
voilà alors on le traite tout au long du
mandat on l'a traité tout au long du
mandat il ya eu des évolutions dans
notre politique de tranquillité publique
je pense notamment avec la création d'un
nouveau simple de sécurité urbaine un
développement des carrières des caméras
de vidéosurveillance etc
donc tout ça effectivement ce sont déjà
des choses qui se sont passées
maintenant je crois que la tranquillité
publique celle affaire de tous et on en
voit souvent la tranquillité publique à
la police municipale par exemple
mais tout ça est bien évidemment plus
puis rifaat auriez plus de
vidéosurveillance quels sont les
engagements vous allez prendre par
exemple alors le déploiement et le
développement des caméras de
vidéosurveillance il se fait il doit
toujours se faire d'une manière
pertinente c'est à dire que ça n'est pas
parce qu'à un moment donné constater
effectivement un fait donc nous
demandons toujours la vie de la police
nationale c'est important d'avoir ce
support est de plus en plus nous faisons
faire en concertation avec les habitants
voilà parce que ce sont des experts
aussi de leur cage d'escalier de leur
immeuble de leur résidence et on le fait
toujours sur le terrain avec les
habitants fuient en cours est une ville
qui a beaucoup évolué en termes urbain
aussi à ces dernières années il ya eu
une nouvelle moyenne de réalisation
aujourd'hui la ville est achevée il ya
encore d'autres projets que vous
aimeriez mené lors d'un prochain mandat
alors j'espère bien que la vie n'est pas
achevé voilà nous avons bien évidemment
de grands projets chacun le sait nous
avons un projet on va dire à 10 ans avec
en 2030 l'arrivée la mise en service du
métro de la ligue 18 donc forcément avec
le quartier qui accueillera la gare donc
c'est un projet un projet à 10 ans avec
des étapes successives qui vont faire
que ce quartier va sortir de terre
mais vous parlez d'urbanisation il est
nécessaire de continuer à construire des
logements à guyancourt comme ailleurs
d'ailleurs mais toujours d'une manière
raisonnée maîtrisé c'est à dire des
logements sociaux mais pas uniquement
sur guyancourt aujourd'hui c'est 50 % de
logements sociaux moment aux alentours
de 48 % de logements sociaux
actuellement sur la ville de bus en
cours alors moi ce que je souhaite c'est
de conserver des équilibres c'est à dire
que chacun puisse trouver à se loger sur
la ville depuis en cours que ce soit des
étudiants et nous travaillons notamment
par exemple avec le crous en ce sens
mais aussi des revenus très modestes
dans le cadre par exemple du logement
social
et puis dans l'accession aidée ou pas
vous parliez du crous ce qui nous amène
à l'université aussi également
l'université qui va rentrer pleinement
dans l'université paris saclay
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines qui est implantée sur sur
guyancourt c'est un enjeu aussi ce
développement et ces mutualisations
alors avec l'agglomération dont vous
faites partie de saint quentin en
yvelines mais aussi de paris saclay oui
c'est très important de conserver enfin
cette université on sait qu'elle est
amenée à se développer et heureusement
j'étais fière présent lors de la visite
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
à l'université nous avons pu échanger et
nous avons beaucoup de projets autour de
cette université et elle doit pleinement
faire partie effectivement de ce plus
grand ensemble
le prochain rendez vous pour vous le 30
novembre oui peut-être fait date qui
sont déjà prévus alors il y aura par la
suite des réunions publiques bien
évidemment et nous y reviendrons merci
françois morton des joueurs venus sur ce
plateau en début de campagne pour les
municipales sur lui en cours je rappelle
que trois autres listes se présentent
pour l'instant olivier paréja avec
décidons ensemble à guyancourt grégory
pape pour la république en en marche et
rodolphe barry sans étiquette mais
soutenu par génération terrain